or on the political news of the week
gone by and ahead CBS news political
correspondent ed O'Keefe joins us now ed
good morning let's start with Joe Biden
finally he is officially in the race
raised more than 6 million dollars in
that first 24 hour period how has that
changed the way things are looking as
far as the Democrats who are running for
president well so far he's meeting
expectations Dana he has maintained his
poll lead and he was able to demonstrate
pretty quickly that he has the financial
support needed to build a campaign from
scratch because that's what he's doing
I'm like most of the other candidates in
the race Biden hasn't had a campaign
operation of his own in about 12 years
and so he's had to go out and
meticulously find people who are gonna
work for him and hope that the money
would come in quickly and it did and it
will continue to in the coming days he
has scheduled some big fundraisers out
in the West Coast and early May and is
also of course seeking out the small
dollar donations that are driving a lot
of the other campaigns especially those
of Bernie Sanders been too O'Rourke and
Kamala Harris and we've seen with the
president with his I'm a young vibrant
man line already raising the age
question how significant do you think
that is going to be for for Biden well
you know Anthony I keep thinking since
that happened yesterday
does America really want a grumpy old
men campaign or are we gonna be looking
for something else you know I love that
movie I was partial to Jack Lemmon no do
Americans really want that and and and
and first of all do Democrats really
want that do that is is Biden setting
himself up and demonstrating the
Democrats look issue number one mission
number one for us get back the White
House this is how we have to do it we
have to remind people this guy is
president we can't afford four more
years of him other Democrats are gonna
argue no let's just focus on the issues
let's try to look ahead let's try to
move on from what's been going on and
we'll see now over the next year or so
whether or not or with it which of those
arguments altum Utley prevails well we
definitely know the gloves of are come
off is this any indication of how the
president sizes up his opponent sure
look we know that he is concerned about
Biden because Republicans know Biden is
uniquely qualified to appeal in this to
voters in the states that Republicans
won narrowly
on election night in 2016 specifically
Pennsylvania where Biden will hold his
first campaign rally on Monday and where
he's basing his campaign headquarters
Michigan Wisconsin potentially Ohio
places like Iowa all across that mid
industrial and agricultural Midwest
items argument is we need to win those
places back I can do that I can make
overtures to the ascendant class and
ascendant voters that make up the
Democratic Party especially black voters
in the south young voters Latino voters
will see but it is a you know it's just
looking at what the president did there
you just wander to yourself is the
country ready to stomach 15 more months
of that well this week we know that
Attorney General Bill bar will be in
front of Congress what can we expect to
hear from him on May 1st you can expect
more fireworks when he testifies before
the House Judiciary Committee than when
he testifies before the Senate Judiciary
Committee it's because the House
Judiciary Committee is controlled by
Democrats of course the Senate Judiciary
Committee is controlled by Lindsey
Graham and Republicans and they are more
likely to treat the Attorney General
with kid gloves compared to Democrats so
Thursday is the is the day to watch when
he goes to see members of the House edie
O'Keefe thanks very much ed thank you